the zombie thought experiment now at
least for me is often presented as AI
because now that's easier as a robot
because that's easier
um
I don't know if it's just because it's
in it's in pop culture now in the form
of films and television shows but it's
it's easier to get to that point of
contemplation I think by imagining
a robot I don't know why exactly I'm
bothered by philosophers talking about
zombies because
it feels like they're missing it's like
talking about
it's reducing
a a joyful experience so like uh
that's like talking about listen when
you fall in love with somebody yeah the
other person is a zombie you don't you
don't know if they're conscious or not
you're just making presumptions and so
on it's like it says philosophers will
do this kind of things they might as
well be a zombie or you know there's no
such thing as love it's just a mutual
Catholic Economist will reduce love to
some kind of mutual calculation that
minimizes risk stability over time right
it's like yeah all right what I want to
do with each of those people yeah is I
want to take I want to find every one of
those philosophers to talk about zombies
and eventually give them one of those
robots and watch them fall in love and
then and see right how their
understanding of how humbled they are by
how little we understand that's the
point of the zombie experiment I mean
sure maybe that's awesome that I mean I
I can't stand for any of it for zombies
is that the thought is that no so for me
I mean I don't like spending much time
on it I think it has limited use for
sure and I under understand your your
annoyance with it but for me what's so
useful about it is it gets you to ask
the same questions you're asking when
you're looking at robots
um if you just run the experiment and
you say okay you know I'm sitting here
with Lex what if I try to trick myself
what's different about the world if
someone tells me actually he's a robot
is essentially what the zombie
experiment is he's over there he has no
conscious experience he's acting obvious
but there's no experience there so it
gets you to ask some interesting
questions one is
okay when it seems impossible I just
think no that's clear that makes no
sense I can't I can't even imagine that
okay what do I think Consciousness is
responsible for what is consciousness
doing in that in that human over there
that is Lex that I can't
fathom
all of your behavior and everything that
you're you're doing and about without
Consciousness so it gets you to ask this
question and these are this is these are
the questions I begin my book with
um what is consciousness doing it gets
you to ask that question in a deeper way
and then I kind of found this alternate
I don't know if other people have done
this but
I found this alternate use for it which
is even more useful to me which is I'm
able to do it sometimes I'm able to just
sit with someone and and you know get my
imagination going and imagine
there really is no conscious experience
there in that person
and what happened for me the first few
times I was able to do this is it
reminded me exactly of how I feel when I
look at complex plant behavior and other
behaviors in nature where I assume
there's no conscious experience
and
to me it just flips everything it just
flips everything on its head it just
gets you to be able it gets you to be
open to possibilities that you were
closed to before and I think that's
useful